variety of plates beams pipes rails bars
and other marketable shapes the men who
guide the Hin got through the rolling
mail are typical of the industry's most
highly trained technicians operation of the
mill might appear entirely automatic but no
mechanical device can take the place of
skill experience and judgment or steel
making is more than a business it is an art
gradually the steel is shaped into new forms
this is a section of railway track and like
every steel product it must be flawless in form
and quality and must meet rigid specifications for
that's the rule in a free competitive Society good
workmanship means good business and competition
guarantees the highest standards of production
Americans today are pioneers though
we travel in Express trains instead
of covered wagons no uncharted territory
remains but there are other frontiers and
we conquer them in the Pioneer way through
our own initiative and resourcefulness and
steal even more than it was for the pioneers
is our ally steel girded buildings over new
frontiers in the sky bridge is made of its
panel rivers and bays and steel machinery
helps bring our mineral wealth into use the
ships that sail our waterway is helping to
make the United States a world leader with
Commerce and Industry our ships of Steel
it's used for farm equipment to help make us the
best fed nation in the world and
our farmers the most prosperous
steal vehicles carry us through the streets of
our busy cities cities whose very
backbone and framework are of Steel
when an American goes on vacation he's
likely to set out across the country in
his own car the car he drives is of Steel
the concrete highway is reinforced with it
from steel comes the weapons to keep our
country free in the traditional American
way our nation's steel companies help America
handle not only the defense needs of the moment
but those of the future this voluntary
production means that our fighting men
wherever they may be have the best equipment
that mil engineer and technician can make
Steele keeps America safe now and a freely growing
and developing steel industry guards our future as
surely as these big guns guns of Steel card the
Freedom and security of America and the entire
free world as our needs increase new mills and
furnaces are constructed these mills provide a
fast life a road for countless thousands of other
workers and businessmen amano makes conveyor belts
for ore mines a bookkeeper in a Great Lakes
shipping company or a clerk will someday sell a
shiny new refrigerator of Steel recent expansion
and improvements privately financed have given
us greater production than all of Russia's
fault or the increased production from our
new plants alone is twice that of Britain's
entire output three times that of France
in Steel's laboratories scientists continually
develop new and better products billions of
dollars of private capital are spent in the
search for new uses for Steel better in safer
ways of making steel new ways to expand
its production to keep it not merely equal
to but ahead of the nation's ever-growing
demands the gigantic electric steelmaking
furnace is an example of the endless
research in this furnace of manufactured
the highest grades of steel for automobiles
aircraft ball bearings surgical instruments
the ingredients to be melted are
dropped into the top of the furnace
however heat has to be increased in some
cases up to 3,500 degrees Fahrenheit for
this enormous heat the furnace uses enough
electric current to light a small city from
three electrodes tremendous man-made
short-circuit sleep to the metal below
the skill and judgment of the Mount
are all important in a job like this
a special instrument is used to judge the
molten metals quality it's pronounced okay
while developing and expanding methods of making
steel the industry scientists also have made
steelmaking safer thanks to their research hazards
are minimized in handling even liquid hot metals
like these and steel is now one of the safest
industries for the men and women who work in it
in this wire manufacturing plant steel
is rolled into a rod and drawn out into
wire grommet will come an infinite variety of
steel products ranging from cables holding up
a great bridge to a tiny pin whatever the final
product the wire is checked to make sure it fits
specifications precisely a tin plate male makes
steel and turns it into tin plate for what are
popularly known as tin cans the so called tin
can a product that has revolutionized American
living actually is only about 1 percent tin
the rest is steel so it's more correct to
call it the steel can the cans from pressed
flattened steel coated with a thin layer of
tin use up three-quarters of America's tin plate
productions and the United States produces more
than half the world's tin plate we also are
the world's best Tim plate customer buying
more of it than the rest of the world combined
steal racing along here at 30 miles an hour is
made into 20 billion cans for food alone each
year many more cans are needed for foil tooth
powder of paint and other products steel cans
have said American products all over the world
the gleaming tin plate is cut into
convenient sheets and before these are
sent out to be made into cans they're
subjected to a thorough examination
a few moments ago we saw battleships
bridges and skyscrapers in smaller ways
to steal carries on it's pioneering
job ways that bring it into the home
and the life of every one of us cookie
cutters pie plates humble but essential
articles stainless steel hands doing a
job that only steel for dude go to work
in the modern processing of food helping
to raise our nation's health standards
steel comes into every home pioneering new ways
to make life easier and better each steel company
buys with the others or the patronage of the best
customers in the world of men and women of America
a steel hairpin for example making for a
woman's happiness every one of us everyday
uses steel in hundreds of ways and we start
using it almost from the instant we're born
America's free competitive economy depends and
thrives on a free competitive steel industry
I'm a razor blade to a spice paper steel
fills our nation steel from a hypodermic
needle to a pipeline that stretches out
across the country steal from a whirling
eggbeater to an enormous suspension bridge
steel from a needle in the hands of a woman
to the hull of the world's fastest ocean
liner steal from the ticking mechanism of
a watch to the framework of the world's tallest
building steel pioneer of progress in America's
past and riches our nation now and opens
new frontiers for America's bright future